una playa se extendía más de 100 metros
debajo de esta vía hoy en día está
desaparecida en esta ciudad del Sur de
California el océano gana terreno
inexorablemente la erosión de la costa y
el corrimiento de tierras está ahora
empujando lentamente algunas casas hacia
el mar
que estas dos casas Están condenadas
debido al desprendimiento
aproximadamente el tercio inferior de la
casa tiene una grieta y se está
deslizando hacia el océano
Así que la ciudad y otros organismos
gubernamentales los han considerado
invivibles
afirma que esta zona es un auténtico
microcosmos de lo que está en juego a lo
largo de los 2000 kilómetros de costa de
California las autoridades de San
Clemente tratan de estabilizar las vías
con toneladas de rocas para reforzar el
dique bajo la línea ferroviaria una
solución solo temporal según el
demócrata Aunque comprendo la caída del
muro de contención a corto plazo está
causando y más ilusiones de la arena y
eso hace que sea cada vez más difícil en
el futuro reconstruir nuestras playas la
alcaldía de San Clemente Pide a las
autoridades federales que la ayuden a
abastecerse de arena otra solución sería
alejar el Ferrocarril de la costa una
operación costosa que pocos residentes
respaldan y que tampoco abordaría el
destino de las viviendas según un
estudio de la agencia americana de
observación oceánica y atmosférica de
aquí a 2050 el deshielo de los glaciares
podría Elevar el nivel del mar de 20
centímetros en California